et on en parle avec notre invité david
libeskind avocat et cofondateur du
collectif robe noir et gilet jaune
bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous vous imaginez une autre issue à ce
procès où selon vous cette condamnation
était dès le départ impossible à tenir
la condamnation
dès le départ était impossible à tenir
puisque le couple avait indiqué qu'un
agent de sécurité leur avait donné
l'autorisation
justement de prendre des objets les
porsche était d'abord et c'est donc à
partir de là je vois pas en quoi en fait
et pour le très bien le rappeler est à
reconnecter les reconnaisse ou par des
vols l'apparition de voile n'était pas
caractérisé puisqu'ils n'ont pas dérobé
on leur a juste de donner l'autorisation
en fait 2 2 voilà de d'emporter avec eux
tu d'objets qui auront envie d'oser de
deux petites valeurs parce que la jambe
fracturée et donc la facture des airs et
d'aidés au profit leur avis divac sans
prôner la finir à la belle
du coup selon vous il ya eu une sorte
d'acharnement à l'encontre de ce couple
de gilet jaune puisque vous le répéter
l'agent de sécurité leur avait donné
l'autorisation de prendre ces objets qui
étaient en plus dégradées en raison de
la situation au fouquet's bien sûr très
fermement puisque a des fois on fait de
de pouvoir
arrêter
les personnes qui avaient pareillement
il
fallait tromper rateront femmes et on a
trouvé parce ces jeunes couples en fait
qui franchement n'avait rien fait de
particulier parce qu'au pire il aura eu
un rappel à la loi au pire en devant ce
tribunal en première instance non le
partage et de poursuivre on était
abandonnés parce que ils vous voulez
donner un exemple il voulait montrer en
fait là l'opinion publique que les
personnes soient qu avait volé ne soit
qu avec la cad et le bouquet serait
sévèrement réclamé condamné pour vous
des départs c'était une sorte de
procédure symbolique à l'encontre de ce
couple
évidemment parce que moi - les forces du
régime est resté en fait qualité par la
coni qui il avait trouvé en possession
de vêtements un vêtement en pe
était issu d'une des boutiques sur la
musette organisé qui avaient été
saccagés et voilà ils l'ont mis en garde
à vue dont est évidemment les vêtements
mais il
est là la loire donc là on a voulu
vraiment à l'époque car un exemple et en
décembre 2019 donc les deux ce couple a
été condamné donc à un mois de prison
avec sursis en première instance une
condamnation qui était dès le départ
disproportionnée donc selon vous
la nation complètement disproportionnée
il y aura même il aura même pas le
risque de se retrouver devant le
tribunal
ils auront vu le parquet aura des swaps
atépa la séduire et les coupables qu'ils
auraient une amende soit en fait a eu un
rappel à la loi du fil lui la valeur la
fed de valeur en fait les objets qui
auraient été dérobées je dire ça n'était
pas en fait inspecter des personnes qui
je le rappelle avait un casier vierge se
trouve pourra juger devant un tribunal
correctionnel et devant plus qu'un prêt
pour être soumis à l'avs et à wervicq
oculaire bien merci beaucoup d'avis de
libeskind d'avoir répondu à nos
questions j'appelle je rappelle que vous
êtes avocat et cofondateur du collectif
robe noir et gilet jaune merci à vous